die justizministerin hat bis heute
nichts davon gehalten aus dem vergehen
ein verbrechen zu machen die
mindeststrafe auf ein volles jahr hoch
zu setzen weil dass kinder nicht schützt
und weil das manchem geringfügigen taten
nicht gerecht werde
hatten sie gestern nicht recht guten
abend frau ministerin nun aber es ist
eine daueraufgabe den kampf gegen
kinderpornografie und kindesmissbrauch
zu führen und deswegen ist es immer
wichtig sich zu überprüfen und alle
maßnahmen die wir ergreifen können eben
auch umzusetzen und deswegen ist es
wichtig das signal zu senden
kindesmissbrauch und kinderpornografie
sind straftaten widerliche straftaten
und es muss sich eben auch in der
strafbarkeit ausdrücken nachdem sie
jetzt für die spd dem zustimmen
die union fordert das schon lange kann
man damit rechnen dass diese
gesetzesänderung ganz schnell kommen
wird ich habe mein haus angewiesen
schnellstmöglich eine entsprechende
regelung vorzulegen
und ich gehe auch davon aus dass das
sehr schnell gelingen kann
wir werden sie es dann sehr genau
anschauen um alle fragen die in dem
zusammenhang sind eben auch mit zu
berücksichtigen aber ja das kann und es
wird auch schnell gehen
der hauptverdächtige von münster war
zwei mal vorbestraft bekam zweimal
verjährung und dann kam es zu diesen
taten er ist ein verdächtiger und nicht
verurteilt was wäre in diesem fall
anders gelaufen wenn es ihre
gesetzesänderung da schon gegeben hätte
diese widerlichen straftaten die in
münster durch hervorragende ermittlungen
ans tageslicht gekommen sind sind
schwere verbrechen sind ist heute schon
ein verbrechen und kann mit einer stadt
mit einer strafe von bis zu 15 jahren
geahndet werden mit anschließender
sicherungsverwahrung das ist auch heute
schon möglich ich kann den einzelfall
weil ich die genauen inhalte die genauen
details nicht kenne nicht bewerten aber
es muss klar sein dass solche
widerlichen straftaten müssen mit der
gesamten härte des gesetzes eben auch
verfolgt werden ich habe aber doch noch
keine antwort gefunden auf die frage was
eine umbenennung des verbrechens des
vergehens in ein verbrechen und eine
erhöhung der mindeststrafe jetzt wirkt
sich aus sicht der kinder die geschützt
werden müssen in der welt verändern wird
ist das nicht nur ein austausch von
artikeln
nein also es ist ganz wichtig dass
dieses signal gesendet wird solche
widerlichen straftaten sind verbrechen
ohne wenn und aber und das werden wir
aussenden
aber es hat eben auch zur folge dass er
der straff rahmen der möglich ist auch
ausgenutzt wird genutzt wird von
richterinnen und richtern und diese
erwartung habe ich eben auch das
gezielte auch entsprechend der schwere
der tat urteile verhängt werden ist
nicht überhaupt das justizministerium
die falsche an sprecher des viele dieser
täter bekennen sich dann später dazu
dass sie mit ihren trieben mit ihren
veranlagungen nicht zurechtkamen
verzweifeln an ihren eigenen tun und
wären durch höhere härtere strafen und
nicht mal durch bessere aufklärung
abzuschrecken gewesen muss nicht an ganz
anderer stelle der staat viel massiver
seine kinder schützen
der kampf für unsere kinder und gegen
diese widerlichen straftaten ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
dazu gehört es auch prävention
beispielsweise zu stärken kinder stark
zu machen aber auch eltern zu
sensibilisieren erzieher lehrer das
oberfeld dass wir noch sensibler auf
reaktion auf signale von kindern
reagieren aber dann zogen auch die
beratungsstellen entsprechend zur
verfügung stellen stehen beispielsweise
was tun sie jetzt konkret als
justizministerin in dieser richtung ich
werde alsbald ein gespräch führen einen
dialog führen mit verantwortlichen mit
politisch verantwortlichen sowohl aus
der polizei aus der justiz aber eben
auch aus der prävention mit dem kindes
mit dem beauftragten gegen
kindesmissbrauch
wir werden uns zusammensetzen und alle
möglichkeiten erörtern die wir haben um
unsere kinder noch besser zu schützen
das heißt das steht am anfang das ist
nicht vollendet dann ein das ist eine
dauerhafte aufgabe ich habe gerade vor
einigen wochen eine bessere möglichkeit
für ermittler beispielsweise gesetze
gesetzgeberisch geschaffen damit die auf
veränderungen dieser dieser
täter reagieren können und zum beispiel
im netz besser ermitteln können und
dieser entwicklung der müssen wir uns
stellen deswegen es ist eine
daueraufgabe und genauso begreife ich es
auch danke für das gespräch und einen
guten abend ich danke ihnen